[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in chris sims pro football
talk of course the former nfl
quarterback
how do you explain that chris well wait
first off
i mean you left me some good candy there
all right i mean who are you gonna vote
for in the heisman i'm not allowed to
know that i'm not allowed to say it they
don't want us to say it publicly or
i would tell you privately but um i'm
not allowed to say it publicly
all right all right cool i understand
that you could text me later why would
you vote
i would vote for trevor lawrence i would
i would i you know
he's he's the best player in college
football for my money i don't you know
again
it's unforeseen circumstances covered 19
all of that that shouldn't hinder him uh
as far as
you know what the vote or what the the
the award really stands for so i would
go with trevor
if you were trevor would you rather go
to the jets or the jags
oh the jaguars probably have a little
bit more in place as far as
talent on the offensive side of the ball
and even some young talent on the
defensive side of the ball
you know that to me is going to be more
of the decision of
do you want to live in the big lights of
new york or do you want to be kind of
under the radar in jacksonville what
suits like the style of life you want to
live
too so um you know ultimately i think
probably at this point right now the
jags are set up a little bit better team
wise than the jets who have a lot of
holes to fill
but you also look at eli manning
doesn't seem like the new york kind of
guy your father who played for the
giants is not a new york kind of guy
joe namath those days are long gone
namath loved
you know the bright lights and broadway
joe but you don't
sam darnold is not a you know a bright
lights new york city kind of guy
either i i think we get i know the
pressure
the expectation level would be so high
if trevor lawrence goes to the jets
it feels like he would get a little bit
more of a
easing in period in jacksonville i i
would agree
i mean you come you know like you're
talking about you come up to new york
the spotlight's on you
immediately and then of course it's
going to be added on to that
is the fact that whoa they got rid of a
top three quarterback pick
to to take on trevor lawrence so how
does that guy do on his new team and
that's going to add to the spotlight and
just the
overall you know uh attention around the
whole scenario
but but to your point with like my dad
eli manning sam darnold even you know i
think trevor lawrence has that
too where yeah they're not like it just
it's even keel let's throw a touchdown
throw an interception you're not really
sure which one they did it's the same
look on their face either way and i
think there is something to that
in the new york city area as far as
balancing your life and all the
you know the fans and that all the
attention around you at all times yeah
it feels like it's the expectation level
is going to be so high
because the jets are so thirsty the jags
almost went to the super bowl a couple
of years ago
the jets you know they get to watch the
super bowl
but i also wondered about this yesterday
we got over the shock of the jets
beating the rams
if i'm the rams what what did i expose
yesterday
that's going to come back and haunt me
or is this just a one-off that the jets
caught him at the right time
but is there are there bigger issues
with the rams
as we look past this jets upset i i i
think
i said this to you two weeks ago when i
was on a monday
where to me there's one big issue with
the rams football team and it's really
about the only issue because they're
really well-rounded in just about every
area but
there it was again dan just go back and
look at the rams schedule
any game their offense struggles it's
lack of run game
and then the bootleg passes aren't there
and just quite honestly
you know the drop back pass game as far
as scheme
and then jared goff in the drop back
pass game and his ability to do things
that way
pocket passer being a you know
surgical that way and making plays off
schedule this is not the strengths
of the rams so they got themselves in a
hole and then they couldn't run the ball
and the bootlegs were gone and it just
all kind of funneled out of control from
there
is there a super bowl contender in the
nfc west
yes i do believe that the ice
the seahawks to me are a super bowl
contender there's no doubt
the seahawks have played better defense
the last five or six weeks
really ever since they left josh allen
and that loss up in buffalo they've been
better
you know i think you see their run game
has shown inklings of popping up here
and in a year with no great defenses in
football
you know this is why i took seattle
versus kansas city in the super bowl
anyways because of the no
off season i thought the defenses would
be handicapped
i just think player football is going to
lend itself to the great quarterbacks
kind of taking over in the big moments
with no crowd noise and all of that with
no great defenses
and it's just going to favor those kind
of guys so yes russell wilson the
seahawk star
contender were you a josh allen guy
prior to the draft
i didn't think you were i was he was my
number one quarterback that year
really i mean yeah yeah a big big josh
out i kind of
lamarr is number one and josh allen is
two in my first rankings
and honestly dan i made a deal with
myself
i backed off the lamar number one
because i got so much crap
from my nfl friends man lamar number one
are you crazy i thought there was maybe
something i didn't know
that maybe you know there was some
character issues or something that i got
so trashed i
honestly backed off lamar a little bit
and ultimately made josh allen my number
one guy but yes i was a huge josh allen
fan
if i said i got to take out mahomes from
the equation
quarterbacks under the age of 27 that
you would take over josh allen
ooh i oh
man i don't it to me that that and i'm
just you know off the top of my head i'm
just going
only guy i'm thinking about really is
him and desean watson
those are those are those guys i think
that are young right that fit that mold
what you're talking about
it's one of those two i mean to me right
right now rogers mahomes russell wilson
i know in totality of their careers
they're better than josh allen
and deshawn watson but man for 2020
football
right now week 15 i don't think you
could say anybody's played better than
josh allen this year except for rogers
and mahomes and you see
like you saw saturday night he can carry
the team at certain moments doesn't
matter what has to be done
and i remind people you know that that
was the same
denver defense that wouldn't let the
chiefs in the end zone five different
times and josh allen got in the end zone
so
he at least deserves to be in that
conversation i'm not saying he's there
yet but he's in that combo
we're talking to chris sims pro football
talk live co-host with mike florio and
of course the former nfl quarterback
let's look at the saints quarterbacking
situation short term long term here
what do you think well they got to go
with drew brees now i mean he obviously
was not at 100
yesterday he didn't look comfortable i
mean you watched it
you know did he look comfortable at any
point during that game
uh looked jumpy in the pocket right
didn't look
like real decisive with decisions there
was a lot of like oh should i throw it
there oh should i throw it and
he didn't know what to do with it so
they caught him on a rusty day
you know of course not hitting on all
cylinders but i
he's still the guy going forward no
doubt i just hope they find the right
balance of still letting the taysom hill
be a factor there because without drew
brees's ability to really throw the ball
down the field i think they need that
taysom hill
run game package to just give them one
other element
to make defenses defend the whole field
when you play the saints
i think they just can't lose sight of
that
you look at kansas city uh they do keep
teams
in games whether it's somebody really
good like the saints or
you know can be some of these other
teams here but
they seem to have an answer for
everything that's just it
it's the person who makes straight a's
but you go how do they make straight a's
because you're watching their study
habits and you go i don't know
now they they do it differently here um
right how dangerous i mean what's the
flaw there
i i mean the flaw is that they're just
going to play with fire here one of
these days and
you know the wrong bounce of the ball or
you know and just it's going to come
down to that
one one play and they're not going to
come through in the clutch and you're
going to go man they lost to a team that
they're better at
better than and they didn't close the
game out or
you know they just were to sleep at the
wheel because they were unmotivated
that's the concern
but also like you know yesterday
i think it also again shows their
versatility too that's what's amazing oh
we're gonna run the ball we're gonna
play defense and
you know we're gonna stop the run and
make drew brees beat us throwing the
football
you know oh this average chiefs defense
yet when you ask them to do something
stop derek henry in the afc championship
game
slow down the shanahan run game in the
super bowl they
they always rise to the occasion so
they're frustrating i'm with you
and we don't i don't think we've seen
them see play a game the whole year
i think they played a lot of b and b
plus games and they still
win and that's where i'm annoyed by them
i'll say this though
their offense needs to be the one that
closes these games out
that's where they're built and that's
that's the unit that needs to put some
of these teams away
as of late and we just haven't seen them
do that you sold on baker mayfield now
i am i you know i think i think
like the last three four weeks the way
he's playing
i think he's finally just comfortable in
the stefanski
offense what's being expected of him and
dan there's you know there's a language
between
quarterback and play caller that you
know i actually heard even
you know bruce arians talking about this
with tom brady yesterday
you know they're they're speaking to you
with some of their play calls more than
just
hey this is the play call but really
we're at offense and an offensive
coordinator getting on the same page is
oh wait he's calling this play on second
down because
well we we talked about this 10 days ago
he's expecting me to look for the big
shot play here
and if i don't have it throw it away you
know it's all those little nuances i
think that they're finally getting
together and that's why you're seeing
baker just confident and playing
playing awesome and i see young
quarterbacks do this and you played the
position
that i gotta throw the ball away like
it's hard
your mentality is never let me just
throw it away your your mentality is to
make a play
it must be difficult for some of these
younger quarterbacks to go
gosh i gotta i gotta just fall down or i
gotta throw it away
right or throw the check down right
they're not used to that and
i i think that's where you know we gotta
give baker a lot of credit think about
it he was he was at oklahoma it was
throw throw throw throw throw throw it
everywhere
and then he got with hugh jackson and it
was like hey awesome let's throw it more
you're the
first pick of the draft and then last
year they got odell beckham jr and they
went hey let's throw it every play let's
keep doing that
and then all of a sudden this year they
were like hey whoa oh we want you to
hand the ball off
and play smart and control the football
so that is an adjustment for a guy like
that and he's done really great in
handling that and they've matured
off the field too i think that's another
aspect you see with cleveland that
stefanski's really brought to the team
i'll leave you with this i have three
quarterbacks
in their first 48 career starts
three current quarterbacks in their
first 48 starts
these three quarterbacks went 28 and 20.
the exact same record are you ready for
this
yes aaron rodgers was 28 and 20.
deshawn watson 28 and 20.
mitchell trubisky 28 and 20.
yeah i know that's awesome it's awesome
uh i'm happy for mitchell trubisky
that's a misleading stat
i'll say that much because two of those
guys were doing a lot of it do you think
he's happy that you're happy for him
chris
i i i probably not he's probably like oh
i've heard that guy saying negative
things about me before screw him too
uh but i think that's the edge in which
he's playing with like i heard matt nagy
in the post game press conference that
he's a different man
well sometimes when you get benched and
you sit over there and you go man i was
making the game too complicated
and then also when you get back in you
just go i'm taking no prisoners
you know screw everybody screw the coach
screw
all this i'm going to be a leader and
and not think too much and do all that
and they found their way here the best
three offensive games of the
uh the whole season the last three weeks
uh good for the bears
and if you made me choose i bet you they
beat the cardinals and end up in the
seventh seed over the cardinals yes
that would be my choice whoa i like it
yeah i like it
um thank you hey uh happy holidays to
you and the family thank you again for
uh all the times you've joined us here
on the program we always appreciate your
insights and uh thanks for joining us
bud no thanks thanks to you thanks to
all the guys happy holidays to you i
appreciate you having me on
that's chris sims pro football talk and
also you can see him on football
night in america we'll